اذا لازلنا واياكم مشاهدينا نتابع مراحل
تنصيب الملك تشارلز ونتابع في هذه اللحظه
الان الرجاليه وهي طبعا تسليم الملك رموزا
ملكيه
كباتاج الكره الذهبيه
والصولجانات الان كما نشاهد خلال مراسم
التتويج طبعا هي ترمز الى جوانب كثيره
ومختلفه من مسؤوليات الملك تشارلز ومنصبه
ايضا قدمت له الكره الذهبيه كما تابعنا
قبل قليل صولجان الذهبي الان في يد الملك
تشيلس الثالث
وغيرها طبعا من الرموز الملكيه الان تنضم
الي مديره مكتب العربيه ريما مكتب ريما
هذه المرحله كيف يمكن الحديث عن ان نتابع
هذا التاج الان على الشاشه وقبل قليل
الصولجان وقبلها
طبعا الكره الذهبيه الصولجان نعم وكذلك
الرموز اخرى لها الكثير من التلالات
اذا نرى صلى
بالذهب يعود تاريخهما الى 1660 و 1695
ولهما دلاله احتفاليه على السلطه ترمز
للسلطه ونرى الملك جالسا الان وهذه هي
المرحله الرابعه
بسيط والتي
تسبلك الج
رم الذكي الذي يرمز الى العالم
يعني حكم العهد
وحكم الملك في بريطانيا والاقطار وباقي
مراحل او اوجه الدوله
وايضا تسلم
الخاتم الخاتم الملكي الذي يرمز للحكم
ايضا يتم تقديس من قبل اسقف كانتربري وتاج
وتاج الامبراطوري
اقديس ادوا
رد تستخدم في المناسبات الاحتفاليه وايضا
عندما يفتتح الملك البرلمان ريما نستمع
للصوت الطبيعي ثم نعود
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا تشارلز الثالث ملكا للمملكه المتحده
كما نشاهد امامنا يرتدي التاج الملكي
البريطاني تاج القديس ادوارد هذا التاج
الذي يستخدم فقط عند تتويج الملك التاج
الذي صنع عام
نشاهده باطار ذهبي صلب مرصع باحجار
الياقوت
وعدد من الاحجار الكريمه الاخرى وضع هذا
التاج اكثر من خمسه ملوك الى سته ملوك
خلال 360 سنه الماضيه التاج الذي يزن اكثر
من
اثنين كيلو جرام مرحله البيعه ريما الان
ما هي اهم المراحل فيها
اذا يجلس الملك تشعل على كرسي العرش
وينحمي اعضاء مجلس النورسات امام الملك
اصبحت شعوب ملكا
ودول الاقامه يعني على كل الاراضي التي هي
تقع تحت المملكه المتحده ونرى انه تم
الاستعانه بالطقس البيزنطي وهو نوع من
الوفاء او من التحيه من قبل الملك سعود
لارسي والده الامير فيليب وهو من اليونان
ومن الكنيسه البيزنطيه
وبهذا اراد اشراك الملك تشونز الكثير من
البدائل التي تقع تحت هذه المسيحي وايضا
باقي الاديان السماويه وهذا
باشاره المذهب والديني داخل بريطانيا
اذا نشاهد واياكم مشاهدينا هذه
الصور المباشره للملك تشارلز الثالث وهو
يتوج ملكا للمملكه المتحده وهو يجلس الان
على كرسي القديس ادوارد او كرسي
التتويج هذا الكرسي صنع عام 1300 استخدم
في مراسم التتويج في كنيسه وست مونستر
الان ينهض الملك تشارلز الثالث ملك
المملكه
المتحده بعد ان توج
بالتاج قبل قليل
[موسيقى]
امامنا تاج القديس ادوارد طبعا وهو يحمل
صولجناني الان في هذه الصور امامنا
الصوره الان ريما ما هي المرحله القادمه
ايضا في تتويج الملك تشارلز كما نشاهد
الان على الشاشه
[موسيقى]
من المراحل الاساسيه والمهمه جدا في تتويج
الملك نرى الملك تشارلز يقف وحاملا
الطولجان
هو دلا
له اهميه
الموقع
والثولوجان اسمه
دور الروحي للملك تشعر
ونرى الملك يترجل ويمشي داخل كنيسه
وبعد قليل سنسمع المرحله النهائيه
والسادسه في مراحل التتويج وهي الولاء او
البيعه والاحتفال بالتتويج بالملك
وهي ربما الان على الشاشه نتابعها جلس
الملك
نستمع قليلا ثم
[موسيقى]
الولاء خلال لحظات
تمسك بهذه الكرسي كرسي الكرامه بفضل الله
القوي
ادعو الله ان يسدد خطاك وان يساعدك على
الصمود دائما
الامام الذي يحدث الان
وهو يكون قد روسيما ملكا بشكل رسمي
عن العقيده
الولاء
فليساعدني الله
خلال الحياه فليساعدني الله
اذا كما شاهدنا واياكم في الصوره قبل قليل
ولي العهد الامير ويليام قام بمبايعه
والده الملك تشارلز الثالث ملكا للمملكه
المتحده
الذين يريدون ان يعبروا عن دعمهم القيام
بذلك مع التفكير الخاص من خلال قول حفظ
الله الملك
اولئك الذين لديهم الكلمات امامهم ان
يتلوها بكاملها اقسم انني سوف اكون وليا
لجلالتك
ولورثتك وخلفائك
فليساعدني الله
[موسيقى]
اذا تبعنا واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام هذا
الجزء من مراسم تتويج الملك تشارلز ملكا
للثالث ملكه لبريطانيا تابعنا قبل قليل
الانحناء ولي العهد البريطاني الامير
ويليام لوالده وتقديم
البيعه وعدد طبعا من الاساقفه قبل قليل
اذا
الوحيد فقط من العائله الملكيه الذي انحنى
وهو الامير ويليام الدوقه الملكي الوحيد
الذي فعل ذلك
لاحفظ الله الملك تشارس
عاش الملك تشارلز
ادام الله في عمر الملك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا هذا جزء مشاهدينا من مراسم تتويج
الملك تشارلز الثالث ملكا
لبريطانيا تابعنا قبل قليل وهو يرتدي او
يقلد التاج الملكي البريطاني سلم بعض
الرموز الملكيه الكره الذهبيه
والصولجناني حملهما بيديه
وصولا الى كرسي او باتجاه كرسي العرش وبعد
ذلك هنا مرحله اخرى من هذه المراسم ربما
مع
الملكه كاملا الان
رمى هل يمكن شرح دوره الملكه كمله الان
وما سيقدم لها في هذا التتويج في هذه
اللحظات
الملكه كمله تكون قد ايضا مسيحات خلال هذا
التتويج دورها ان تكون الى جانب الملك
الانظار كلها اليوم على الملك تشارلز
الثلاثه وحتى مثلا الملابس التي يرتديها
تعود الى عام 1821
ولي العهد اول من قدم البيعه او اعلن
الولاء للملك ومن ثم الحضور من يرغب يقوم
بذلك لانه البروتوكول يقتضي بان لا يكون
هناك ضمن الحضور ملوك اخرين ولكن هذه
التقاليد وطقوس قديمه مع التطور وتمدن
العائله الملكيه
يكون يعني يكون هناك ملوك من باقي الدول
ولكن من يرغب
الملكه ربما
الملكه تاج كم
يلا عقلي
سيتم ارتداء اثناء التتويج وستقسم ايضا
ولديها ايضا القادم الملكي
قديم يعني لن يتم
تاج جديد لكمالله لعصر الانفاق وايضا لكي
لا يكون ثمن التتويج باهضا استخدمت تاج
قديم ونرى في التاج الملكه ماري هذا التاج
صنع عام
1911 يقال بان قياسات هذا التاج عدي الى
يناسب الملكه القرينه كاملا
عدلت يناسب الملكه
كاملا وعلى فكره لم يعد ولم تعد التسميه
الملكه القرينه ولكن يبدو ان هناك اصرار
من قبل الملك تشارلز ان تكون ملكه
بكل بكل المقاييس نذكر هنا ان كل عائله
كمله موجوده حتى زوجها الاول وطليقها
موجود داخل الحفل وايضا ابنائها من طليقها
واولادها من طليقها الاول واحفادها
وبالتالي كمان الان اصبحت ملكه متوجه من
قبل اعلى هيئه
منوطه بهكذا دور في المملكه المتحده اذا
كاملا اصبحت ملكه من خلال هذه الصور التي
تابعناها بعد ان قلد تاج الملكه ماريو
الذي صنع عام 19
يتكون طبعا من ثلاث ماسات من الكولينان
الثالثه والرابعه والخامسه اقتطعت من اكبر
ماسه في العالم اربعه من اصل ثمانيه من
الاقواس القابله للفصل عن التاج كانت قد
ازيلت وتاج من الفضه طبعا مرصع ب 2200
ماسه يزن 590 غراما الملكه تجلس الان ايضا
امامنا على
هذه
المراسم مراسم تتويج طبعا الملك تشارلز
الثالث ملك بريطانيا الملكه اكمل جزء طبعا
من هذا التتويج كما شاهدنا قبل قليل
اعطائها او تقليدها تاج الملكه ماري
ومناولتها هذا التاج وبعد ذلك وضع على راس
الملكه كامل
بعد ان يعني اعطيت هذا التاج قلدت هذا
التاج لبسته ايضا ما هي المرحله ايضا التي
تنتظر هذا التتويج الان
نحن اصبحنا تقريبا في المراحل النهائيه
الملك والملكه بعد قليل ستبدا الاحتفالات
واعلان الولاء
واصبحنا تقريبا في المراحل النهائيه
وهنا اود ان اشير الى انك بلا
تغيرت صوره كامله كثيرا في المجتمع
البريطاني اصبحت ملكه محبوبه لديها الكثير
من النشاطات الاجتماعيه والخيريه
والثقافيه وتغير صوره كاملا
تغييرا كاملا من السيده او عشيقه الى
الاقرب الى قلب الملك والاكثر تاثيرا عليه
والى سيده محبوبه ومحترمه من قبل المجتمع
البريطاني ويعني
ويعني يذكر لصالح كمال لانها امراه ذكيه
تمكنت من قلب الصوره التي كانت في ذهني
المجتمع البريطاني من عشيقه الى ملكه
متوجه
بعد قليل ايضا بعدها انتهاء الحفل وعند
انتهاء مراسم التتويج ستنتقل الملكه
والملك في العربه الذهبيه وهي عربه مختلفه
تماما عن التي رايناها اثناء قدوم الملك
من باكينغه الى
عندما ينتهي تتويج ويصبح ملكا
مرسوما وممسوحا من اعلى الهيئات الكنسيه
في بريطانيا والمملكه المتحده
يمتطي هو والملكه العرب الذهبيه وعمرها
اكثر من 250 عام
ا مصنوعه من الخشب ومطليه بالذهب
وسيقوم برحله مماثله التي رايناها من من
الى باتنهام وسيرافق بالاف القوات المسلحه
والفرقه الموسيقيه طبعا الان الملك تشارلز
الثالث وعن يمينه وعن يساره
الاساقفه ايضا في هذه الصور ربما كنت
تشاهدينها ايضا
معي هذه مرحله جديده بعد ان تم تتويج
الملكه كاملا قبل قليل بتاج
تاج الملكي طبعا تاج ماري
الملكه ماري طبعا
هي المرحله النهائيه وهي الاحتفاليه
والبيعه هي نوع من مسيره داخل الكنيسه
يرافق الملك الاساقفه كما نرى على الشاشه
والان
الاحتفال بالملك الجديد
والملكه من خلال تراتيل وصلوات تتلى
ومسيره داخل كنيسه هي من اقدم الكنائس في
المملكه المتحده وشهدت على تتويج تقريبا
اذا لازلنا نتابع مشاهدينا واياكم مراحل
تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث ملكا للمملكه
المتحده الزميله مكتبي تتحدث الان عن
مسيره تعقب تتويج الملك والملكه ايضا حتى
كامل هذه التيجان قبل قليل
ريما ابقى معي ابقى معي انتقل الى كارينا
كرينه كامل ايضا مراسله العربيه من لندن
كارينا كيف يتابع البريطانيون هذه
المراسم من مراسم التتويج خارج قصر
باكنجهام خارج ايضا كنيسه كل من احتشد من
قدم الى لندن لمتابعه هذا الحدث التاريخي
والضخم في التاريخ البريطاني
نعم بالفعل يعني منذ ايام وتتوافد الحشود
على هذه المناطق المركزيه في لندن
العديدون متواجدون منذ ايام طويله وامضوا
عده ليالي في الشارع اذا كنت تستمع الى
هتافات نحن متواجدون الان في تظاهره سلميه
يبدو انها بقياده بعض الحركات الجمهوريه
ونذكر هنا المشاهدين انه قد تم اعتقال
زعيم احدى هذه الحركات الجمهوريه صباح
اليوم ولكن نحن متواجدون الان يعني في
مكاننا
ضمن او في قلب هذه المظاهره الان ولكن هذا
يعني قد نقول اقليه ضئيله جدا من
المواطنون المتواجدون الذين قدموا الى
لندن للمشاركه في هذا الاحتفال المصطفون
منذ ساعات طويله عندما فتحت المناطق
المختلفه لمشاهده الموكب والمناطق
الرئيسيه التي يحتشد فيها
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
قد تصل الى عشرات الالاف من الاشخاص الكل
في حاله احتفال في حاله ترقب وربما
المرحله القادمه هذا الموكب هو وهي الفرصه
الاساسيه الان ليتابع الجميع هذا
الاستعراض العسكريه الذي من المتوقع ان
يشمل اكثر من 4000 ربما حتى 5000 من عناصر
القوات
كميه كبيره ايضا من اعضاء الفرق الموسيقيه
كارينا الان هناك مرحله ايضا ربما بدايه
هذا الاحتفال بالملك تشارلز نستمع فقط ثم
نعود
تجنب الاداء مهمه
ان اشكر الله
العلي القدير الله دائم عبر المسيح
حتى الان
بفضل
رحمتك سيكون مدافع عن العقيده
وحامي شعبي
ومعه سنتعلم سبل الخدمه
والتعاطف والحب وان الكلمه الطيبه التي
بدات فيه اليوم يمكن ان تستكمل في ايام
المسيح
وبالتالي
بالملائكه وكذلك رفاق الجنه نحن نسمن هذا
التشريف
اذا ريما الصلوات طقوس دينيه ايضا بدايه
هذا
الاحتفال بعد ان توج تشارلز ثالث ملكا كيف
يمكن التعليق عليها
[موسيقى]
المرحله النهائيه الان السادسه الاحتفال
عاده يبدا بالصلوات الدينيه استخدمت تغسل
بيزنطي هناك اساقفه من الشرق الاوسط
تحديدا من القدس وايضا هناك عمليه اشراك
للكثير من الاديان السماويه داخل هذه
الكنيسه قطر الملك
اديلو بناء على طلب شخصيا ليكون قسما
لحمايه كل الاديان
وفي اللحظات
لعمليه التتويج هذه
وهي مرحله احتفاليه
[موسيقى]
والضيعه والولاء للملك من قبل الحضور
هناك ترجيح
ريما يعني فيما كتب عن جدول هذا التتويج
ان يدخل طبعا الى مصلى القديس ادوارد
الملك سيخلع تاج القديس ادوارد يضع ايضا
على راسه تاج اخر باسم تاج الامبراطوريه
بعد ذلك يغادر ينضم الى الموكب الذي
سيغادر كنيسه ويست مونستر باتجاه قصر
باكينغهام مره اخرى
تم وضعها على راسه لحظه التتويج وعمليه
الانتفاء حصلت داخل الاربع جدران
قماشيه نهضه الجلوس على كرسي العرش عندما
يخلص
بمراسم تراثق الملك والملكه في العربه
الذهبيه والكثير من القوات المسلحه تقريبا
4000 شخص من الفرقه الموسيقيه وتقريبا
7000 مجمل القوات المسلحه التي ترافق
الملك سيكون هناك ايضا عرض جوي فوق سماء
العاصمه تحيه للملاك
وطبعا في لحظات الاخيره من كل المراسم
يعني تقريبا خلال ساعه يقف الملك على
الشرطه بتنغام والبانيكا بحضور الاح سيكون
هناك الاحفاد وورثاء العرش في الشرطه
وربما ولي العهد لتحيه الجماهير ومن جاء
لتحيه الملك
عود مره اخرى الى
اللحظات الاخيره الجميع يقف تحيه طبعا
للملك وهي هذه هي المراسم او الوجوه
الاحتفاليه للملك الجديد وحكما الملكه
كارينا سيكون هناك تشكيلات جويه فوق القصر
او عروض ايضا كذلك
جويه ما هي التفاصيلها هي ستعقب خروج
الملك من
يعني كنيسه من السرابي اليس صحيحا
وربما يعني حاله الطقس سيئه اليوم ونذكر
الكل كان يتحدث انه ايضا في يوم تتويج
الملكه اليزابيث عام 53
كانت ايضا هناك امطار شديده ربما الامطار
اليوم اخف من تلك التي كانت عامه
حول امكانيه اقامه هذه الاستعراضات الجويه
نظرا لسوء حاله الجو ولكن حتى الساعه
اعتقد الجو يعني ليس سيء بدرجه التي كان
يخشاها البعض الملفت انه هذه الاستعراضات
سوف تشمل 60 طائره عسكريه
وسيتابعها الملك من شرفه قصر ولكنها لم
تختصر فقط على العاصمه لندن ولكن ستكون
هناك استعراضات في عده مناطق اخرى حول
المملكه المتحده ستشارك فيها عناصر القوات
الجويه التركيز الان من ناحيه المتواجدين
على الارض والمتابعين طبعا عبر شاشات
التلفزيون حول العالم يتحول الى الموكب
والاسئله الان الدائره من هم اعضاء
العائله الملكه او الملكيه ستشارك رسميا
في هذا الموكب نحن نعرف انه هناك كما ذكرت
الزميله ديمه يعني ما بين 4500 من عناصر
القوات المسلحه بما فيهم ايضا يعني اعضاء
قوات المسلحه او ممثلون من 30 دوله اخرى
اغلبهم طبعا من دول الكومن ولكن ماذا عن
افراد العائله الملكيه نفهم انه يعني خلف
العرب الذهبيه التي ستنقل الملك تشارلد
والملكه كامله ستكون عائله الملك ويليام
وزوجته
واولادهم الثلاثه في عربه ثانيه خلف الملك
هذا ما نفهمه ولكن ماذا عن مثلا الاميره
ان وايضا الامير اندرو هل سيشاركان ايضا
في هذا الموكب بشكل رسمي هذا هو السؤال
ثانيا ايضا سيقف في شرطه القصر الى جانب
الملك هل سيخرج وحده وهو وكامله من هم
الاعضاء من العائله التي سيخسرهم يعني
التواجد في هذا المكان ومتابعه التحيه
العسكريه
بعد انتهاء الموكب وبالمناسبه من المتوقع
ان يستمر لمده 45 دقيقه من وسمنت سيقطع
نفس الطريق
باتجاه ميدان البرلمان شارع ويطول بجوار
ميدان ترا فالجر قوس ادرارتي ومن ثم ضمال
وبالنهايه يصل الى قصر باكيهام سيتقبل
الملك التحيه العسكريه سنسمع ايضا صوت
اطلاق التحيات البندقيه
والطلقات الناريه كذلك في هذه الاثناء
وفي نهايه الامر سيصل الى الشرفه ويتابع
هذه الاستعراضات الجويه فهذا ما ننتظره
اسئله عديده دائره هناك تقريبا اجماع انه
الامير هاري لن يعني يكون من بين المدعوين
للوقوف في شرفه القصر هناك حتى من يقول
انه قد يغادر الامير هاري مباشره بعد
نهايه المراسم الرسميه في دير وسميتر
فبالتالي التركيز الان يتحول من كل هذه
الطقوس التاريخيه داخل الكنيسه الى ما
يحدث في الشارع واقول لك ايضا انه رغم سوء
حاله الجو الامطار
تنهال علينا منذ الصباح هذا يعني ربما لم
يقلل من الحماس الموجود هنا في الشارع
الكل واقف منذ ساعات طويله بغض النظر عن
سوء حاله الطقس التي ربما من يعيش في
بريطانيا اعتاد على تقبلها في كل الاحوال
اعود مره اخرى الى ريما مكتبي
ريما مرحله مرحله المسح مسح الملك
بالزيت
متى ستكون هذه المرحله
انتهت كانت المرحله الثالثه وكانت خلف
الجدران بعيدا عن
الكاميرا وهذا تقليد ايضا جرى اثناء تتويج
الملكه اليزابيث قبل 70 عاما وتم يعني جلب
جدران من القماش الان هي صلوات وبركات من
قبل اوسكو كانتربري
لملك والملكه وهي المرحله الاحتفاليه
تحضيرا لخروج الملك من
وايضا
من ملوك وزعماء الدول ورؤساء الدول يخرجون
من قاعه من السر بعد قليل ويمكن القول ان
الخطر الامني حول مرستر يتلاشى مع خروج
هذا الكم الهائل من كبار الشخصيات والتي
من واجب على مسؤوليه الحكومه البريطانيه
تامين الضيوف امنيا وسياسيا لدى خروج
الضيوف وايضا لدى
ذهاب الملك باتجاه قصري باكينغهام تكون
المهمه الاساسيه للقوات المسلحه والاجهزه
الامنيه تامين سلامه الملك
[موسيقى]
حتى قصر باكينغه
ولنا يعني حتى موضوع اختيار الاساقفه تم
اشراك النساء في هذه المراسم تم اشرافك
ايضا
الشخصيات من اصول افريقيه تم اشراك اساقفه
من الشرق الاوسط في محاوله لاعطاء الكثير
من الدلالات
لبريطانيا كذلك بعد قليل الموكب الذي سيقل
الملك تشارلز الثالث والملك ايضا
ياتي سؤال طرحته زميلتنا كارينا كامل عن
من هم اعضاء العائله المالكه الذين
سيشاركون في في هذا الموكب هل هناك من
ترجيحات ريما
تركوا الكثير يعني بعض الامور تركت للحظه
الاخيره مثلا الكثير قال ان الملك سيرتدي
الزي العسكري لم يرتدي ارتدى الثوب موضوع
العائله الملكيه ايضا ترك للحظه الاخيره
ارادت
او باكينج ان لا يكون القصف
او التويج العائله الملكيه محاطه بالكثير
من الاشاعات
وقصر افراء لذا لم يعلن عن اسماء العائله
الملكيه التي ستثير خلف الملك تشارلز
ما نعرف ان الملك اراد ان يعطي الشعب صوره
ان العائله الملكيه عددها اصغر الان موضوع
التوريث واضح بشكل مباشر الامير ويليام
ولي العهد وابن الامير ويليام يتولى العرش
من بعض الامير ويليام تراتبيه واضحه عائله
ملكيه مصغره وليس الكثير من
هذه الصوره التي يريد الملك تشارلز ان
يعطيها للناس وصل الكثير من التساؤلات
لاحظنا ان الاميره ان وهي تعتبر الصديقه
والشقيقه الاقرب للملك تشارل هي فيزياء
العسكري وكما قالت الزميله كارينا لن يكون
الامير هاني شزيه العسكري
وليس واضحا اذا ما سيحضر الكثير من
الفعاليات تعمد قصر باكيهام ان يسحب قضيه
القضيه الجزليه حول الامير هاري من
التداول اثناء التتويج الانظار على الملك
وليس على ما تقوله الصحافه
دعيني اشرك معي عضو حزب المحافظين
البريطاني احمد ياسين سيد احمد مرحبا بك
معي في هذه اللحظات التي نشاهد فيها تتويج
تشيلز الثالث ملكا للمملكه المتحده
ونحن نعرف بان الملكه الراحل اليزابيث
عرفت بحياتها
السياسي الملك تشيلسي هل يسير على ذات
النهج
نعم من الواضح يعني منذ وفاه الملكه
اليزابيث الثانيه بان الملك تشارلي الثالث
يحافظ على نفس التقاليد بعدم تدخل الملك
في الشؤون السياسيه في البلاد يعني هذا
هذا الملف كان كان يسير بعض الخوف وبعض
التساؤلات قبل وفاه الملكه لان الملك
تشارلز عندما كان اميرا كان معروف عن
انتقاداته الحاده التي كان يتدخل من
خلالها في الشؤون السياسيه في البلاد وحتى
في شؤون الداخليه لبلدان اخرى وكان يخشى
من ان الملك الثالث ان يستمر بمثل هذا
الدور بعد العرش ولكن من الواضح جدا بانه
يعني التزم التقاليد المعترف بها بان
الملك يجب الا يتدخل في الشؤون السياسيه
للبلاد ويقتصر دوره فقط على الواجبات
الملكيه التي من المفترض ان يقوم بها طيب
تحديات كذلك ايضا التي تواجه ملك تشارلز
في
المرحله القادمه رينا كيف ريم عفوا كيف
يمكن الحديث عنها او اجمالها يعني في عدد
من النقاط
[موسيقى]
ريما
كنت اسال عن التحديات
المنتظره
للملك تشارلز الثالث
بالنسبه للشعب البريطاني وعلى علاقه وثيقه
وعصريه التحدي الاخر هو
الافقاد دول الكومنكا كانت قالت انها تريد
ان تنفصل دول اخرى قالت لا نريد ان نكون
جزء من الملكيه نريد ان نكون جمهوريه
هو
السياسي الذي يح
به ولكن الابقاء على الحياد
يحاول ان يلعب الملك ولكن كسروا في لحظات
محدوده جدا منذ
اصبح لاحظنا ان الملك تشارلز زارا معسكره
لتدريب القوات الاوكرانيه من قبل القوات
البريطانيه على الاراضي
البريطانيه كانت هذه خطوه سياسيه مهمه جدا
لانه اراد ان يعني يساعد في هذا الموضوع
يساعد دور الحكومه دور بريطانيا وان يعطي
صوره بان بريطانيا تقف بوجه اي اعتداء على
اوروبا لانها على القاره الاوروبيه فيكون
ايضا دور الابقاء على علاقات ممتازه مع
دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي مع الدول
النفطيه الاقتصاد البريطاني يعاني جدا دور
الملكيه ليس له دور تنفيذي في الحياه
السياسيه البريطانيه ولكن هناك علاقات
خاصه وعلاقات غير مباشره بين الملكيه
والحكومه واسم حاولت يعني الحكومه
البريطانيه والدوله اخفائها لاحظ في بعض
المحلات وبعض الاماكن خاصه لدى وفاه
الملكه اليزابيث انه تقوم احيانا بالاتصال
بالنواب بالوزراء بالسؤال عنهم وبتمرير
رسائل سياسيه معينه
بموضوع البيئه
الامير البيئي كان امير او كان وليان
العهد مهتم بالبيئه بشكل كبير
وايضا التاثير في هكذا ملفات
السياسات الاجتماعيه اذا دوره تش
ارلز بالموضوع
داخلي هو حساس جدا لانه مسير وسيحاول
الابقاء على الحياه مع التمايز عن والدته
الملكه اليزابيث هناك الكثير من التحديات
الداخليه العائله الملكيه تعاني الامير
هاري فجر قنبله من العيار الثقيل من خلال
الكتاب الذي نشروا علاقته بزوجته
ويعني فجر
داخل العائله الملكيه بالقول انه الملكه
لم تكن
زوجه اب جيده
الاشاره للكثير من اساءه المعامله داخل
العائله الملكيه سيكون على الملك تشارلز
ان يلعب دور الاب العطوف ولكن الملك
الحازم عليه ان يعيد الامير هاري الى
العائله من دون ان يعطي كره بانه ملك ضعيف
وهذا دور ليس بسهل ولا يريد المزيد من
الفضائح من داخل العائله الملكيه ويريد
امن الوراثه الشرعيه للامير ويليام من دون
مشاكل في داخل العائله الملكيه يعني ربما
ايضا من اللافت في هذا الحفل حفل تتويج
والمراسم التتويج الكبرى
للملكز الثالث هي الفرق حتى الموسيقيه
التي نتابعها منذ اليوم عن نوع الموسيقى
عن اهتمام حتى الملك تشارلز بالموسيقى
وبالفنون ايضا كيف يمكن الحديث عنها
الفرقه الموسيقيه ضخمه جيئه بها يعني من
داخل بريطانيا وايضا من الخارج يعني مثلا
تم الاستعانه
مغنيات مغنيات الاوبرا الشهيرات
للقيام بالحفل اليوم هناك يعني نوع من
الاشراك لعدد كبير من الفنانين مثلا وجدنا
من اهم الممثلات في بريطانيا موجوده داخل
قصر
[موسيقى]
ابي داخل الكنيسه يعني
هناك حفله موسيقيه ضخمه في وينزر طلب من
عدد من الفنانين الحضور للمشاركه مثل جون
مغنيين المشاهير في بريطانيا يعني عدد من
الشخصيات والممثلين موجود تم اشراك
الافراق الموسيقيه المغ
نيه
وهي مغنيه اوبرا جنوب افريقيا
ويعني حتى هي صدمت عندما طلب منها الغ
ناء الملكيه
طيب نحن
نشاهد الان ريما هذه العربه الذهبيه ربما
وهي تتجه الى كنيسه وست مونستر الان
امامنا على الشاشه تاهبا
لخروج الملك تشارلز الثالث وزوجته الملكه
كملا اذا نشاهد هذه العربه الذهبيه والتي
ستقل الملك تشارلز الثالث وزوجته الملكه
كاملا
منستر من كنيسه مانستر abb اتجاه قصر
باكينغهام في موكب كبير وموكب
مهيب ايضا بعد ان جرت كل مراحل التتويج
ربما الملك تشارلز الثالث هذه العربه التي
بنيت عام 1762 استخدمت في كافه مراسم
التتويج منذ عام 18
هي كما ذكرت الزميله ريما مصنوعه من الخشب
المكسور باوراق الذهب طبعا كذلك هناك
الواح مزينه بالرسومات كما نشاهد امامنا
في هذه العربات يمتد طولها لاكثر من سبعه
امتار تزن اربعه اطنان كما نشاهد واياكم
في هذه
الصوره امامنا طيب السيد احمد اعود لك من
جديد للسؤال عن دور الملك في المرحله
القادمه في المحافظه وتعزيز علاقات
بريطانيا مع الدول الصديقه الشركه ايضا
كذلك ما المطلوب منه
بالتاكيد هناك يعني تحديات كبيره جدا بهذا
الخصوص امام الملك تشارلز لان يعني هناك
تحديات وايضا في نفس الوقت هناك فرص كبيره
تزامنا مع استلام الملك تشارلز الثالث
العرش البريطاني يجب ربط هذا الحدث مع
خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي وهنا
الاهميه التي يجب ان يعطيها الملك تشارلز
بشكل كبير وبشكل شامل لاعاده تفعيل مجموعه
يعني هناك تحديات كبيره لاعاده تفعيل هذه
المجموعه واعطائها الدور الاساسي بالنسبه
لجعل بريطانيا عظمى مره اخرى يعني 56 بلدا
هم اعضاء مجموعه
15 بلدا منهم يحملون التاج الملكي
البريطاني هذه المجموعه تغيرت في مقوماتها
في ابعادها الاقتصاديه والسياسيه بشكل
كبير منذ يعني على مر العقود الماضيه ولكن
الان بريطانيا طالما خرجت من الاتحاد
الاوروبي بامكانها ان تعطي الزخم الجديد
لان عندما انضمت بريطانيا الاتحاد
الاوروبي هذا الدور في قياده مجموعه
ثلاثه وتضارب بشكل كبير جدا لان يعني
عضويتها في الاتحاد الاوروبي كان لنوع ما
يتناقض مع امكانيتها ان تستمر في قياده
مجموعه
بالرغم من ذلك هناك هناك امكانيات كبيره
جدا لاعاده تفعيل هذه المجموعه هناك يعني
دول تغيرت في مقوماتها الاقتصاديه بشكل
كبير مثلا الهند الهند كانت تعتمد عندما
خرجت عندما انتهت الامبراطوريه البريطانيه
كانت تعتن بشكل اساسي على المساعدات
البريطانيه التي كانت تقدم الى الهند ولكن
حاليا الاقتصاد الهندي
قد اقتصاد البريطاني والملفت الانتباه ان
الهند ما زالت ما زالت او تاخذ المساعدات
الماليه التي يعني تقليديه كانت تستلمها
من قبل لذلك هناك يعني تحديات كبيره جدا
وفرص في نفس الوقت امام الملك تشارلز لكي
يعيد تفعيل مجموعه ومن خلال ذلك يمكن ان
تعطى
بريطانيا الجديده بعد خروجها من ابتعاد
الاوروبي الوجه العالمي التي يعني تحاول
بلورته وتحاول ايضاحه منذ خروجها من
الاتحاد الاوروبي نحن لا زلنا في انتظار
الخروج الملك تشارلز الثالث وزوجته الملكه
كاملا من كنيسه
ابي بعد طبعا اتابعنا واياكم مراسم تتويج
الملك تشارلز الثالث انتقل الى كارينا
كامل مراسله العربيه من لندن لكن هذه
المره انا اسال عن الاحتفالات
وايضا ان كانت هناك من يعني مظاهر موجوده
في
الاحتفال خارج لندن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الجو احتفاليه سودا المملكه المتحده منذ
ايام طويله في كل شوارع المملكه المتحده
تبدو الاعلام الملكيه والعلم البريطاني
وكل الرموز الملكيه المختلفه في كل
المتاجر وفي كل المناطق التسوق الرئيسيه
حتى في كل المدارس البريطانيه يوم امس
الجمعه مثلا كل المدارس اقامت احتفالات
للطلاب وللاطفال والصغار حفلات الشاي
التقليديه فالكل يشارك بطرق مختلفه الكل
يعرف ايضا انه حفلات الحدائق الجاردن من
يعني احتفالات المعروفه والمحبوبه هنا في
المملكه المتحده وكانت هناك دعوه من الملك
للاشخاص العاديين المواطنين حول المملكه
المتحده لاقامه لاقامه احتفالات مصغره في
شوارعهم وقدموا طلبات للمجالس المحليه
لاغلاق الشوارع كي لا يعني تكون هناك حركه
مرور في هذه المناطق وبالتالي كل الجيران
وكل المقيمين في هذه المناطق المختلفه
قادرين على اقامه احتفالات في شوارعهم
ويعني المشاركه في هذا الاحتفال وفي هذا
اليوم التاريخي وهذا حدث فعليا رغم ربما
حاله الطقس ربما والامطار ولكن في اي مكان
تذهب اليه ستشعر فعليا انه هناك جو احتفال
كبير يشارك فيه الملايين من كل الاجناس
وكل الجهات المختلفه ومن كل الاعمار هذا
بالنسبه لما يجري خلال اليوم يوم غد بطبع
ونحن يعني لم تنتهي بعد مراسم اليوم نتوجه
الان الى المرحله التي ستكون خارج ديرو
وهذا الموكب الذي ننتظره دقائق تفرقنا عن
خروج الملك فعليا عن كنيسه وبدء هذا
الموكب الرسمي الذي سيكون فعليا يعني احد
اكبر الاستعراضات العسكريه التي شهدتها
بريطانيا في تاريخها المعاصر مشاركه ضخمه
جدا لعناصر القوات المسلحه وايضا الكل
يعرف مدى حب الملك تشارلز للفن والموسيقى
ما برز من خلال كل المقاطع المختلفه يعني
الموسيقى التي سمعناها القطع الموسيقيه
المختلفه داخل هذا الاحتفال وفي الدير
ولكن ايضا سنستمع الى المزيد من القطع
الموسيقيه من خلال الفرقه العسكريه او
الموسيقى العسكريه خلال هذا الموكب
كل الاحتفالات ستستمر على مدار ساعات
القادمه بما فيها الاستعراضات الجويه
وقبول التحيه في شرفه القصر وطبعا هذا الى
جانب اعضاء العائله الملكيه الذين سيقفون
الى جانب الملك في الشرفه ولكن يوم غد
ربما التركيز يتحول الى قلعه ونزر حيث
بالمناسبه كانت تقيم الملكه اليزابيث خاصه
في سنواتها الاخيره حيث يعني الان توجه
الملك او عفوا الامير ويليام وزوجته
انتقلا
حيث كان في قصر كنز والان اصبح قصر وينزر
هو المقر الرئيسي لهما وحتى الامير جورج
وشارليت الان يعني يذهبان الى مدرسه بجوار
هذا القصر
كل الانظار ستتوجه الى قلعه وين غد لاقامه
هذا الحفل الكبير الكل يتذكر الحفل الذي
اقيم بالمناسبه اليوبيل البلاتيني للملكه
اليزابيث الذي شارك فيه من ابرز نجوم الفن
من حول العالم ليس فقط من بريطانيا ولكن
من كل انحاء العالم
وكانت هناك اعداد كبيره تابعت الحفل في
شوارع لندن انحفر حين كان في في الساحه
الرئيسيه امام قصر ولكن طبعا ايضا كان
متلفز حول العالم فبالتالي هذا الاحتفال
يوم غد في وسمسر عفوا في وينزر هو ساكون
التركيز الرئيسي يوم الاحد ولكن هناك ايضا
يوم ثالث من الاحتفالات يوم الاثنين وهي
الاج الرسميه التي اصر عليها الملك وكان
هناك جدل دائر عن مدى جدوى اقامه هذه
الاجازه الرسميه هل هناك مثلا انتاجيه
مفقوده من الممكن ان يؤثر ذلك مثلا على
الاقتصاد بشكل سلبي ولكن
الملكه حريص على المنح اجازه اضافيه يوم
اضافي فرصه
لمره ثانيه نفس يعني الطموح للملك ان تكون
هناك فرصه لاكبر عدد ممكن من الاشخاص
المشاركه في الاحتفال اجازه من العمل
الذهاب الى منازل عائلاتهم واقاربهم
للمشاركه بشكل مباشر في هذا اليوم ولكن
اليوم الاثنين يعني اضافه الى انه يوم
اجازه رسم يمنح فرصه الراحه للبعض
والمشاركه في الحدث هو ايضا يوم يعني يحس
فيه الملك المواطن العادي على القيام
بالاعمال الخيريه واعمال التطوع
البالنتيرن وهناك مثلا يعني في اشاره ايضا
الى مدى يعني اقبال الملك على التكنولوجيا
الحديثه وتطوير العائله الملكيه هناك
تطبيق تم اطلاقه فعليا يمكن تنزيله على
الهاتف او اي اجهزه
والادخال العنوان وبالتالي يطلع الشخص على
فرص التطوع او فرص الاعمال الخيريه التي
يمكن ان يقوم بها يوم الاثنين وهي ايضا
يعني قد تكون يعني رمز صغير ربما او اشاره
صغيره الى ان كل شخص يمكنه الاحتفال بحاله
الحدث ولكن في نفس الوقت ايضا مساعده
اخرين المتضررين والفقراء
طيب اعود مره اخرى الى الزميله ربما مكتبي
الان هل انتهت بشكل كامل مراسم تتويج
الملك تشارلز ام فقط داخل كنيسه مانستر
بريطانيا والرسائل التي ترسلها هو موضوع
الوقت يعني عندما يقال انه البرنامج يبدا
الساعه 10:20 بتوقيت بريطانيا يعني فعلا
وهذه من الامور التي تحاول بريطانيا تقول
اننا صعب منتظم ومنضبط وهي من الرسائل
الثقافيه
التي يعطيها قصر باكيهام عن الشعب
البريطاني وعن الملكيه في المسيره التي
على وسط ان تبدا ونرى ان الاطقف جاهزا
وجميع وقوفا للخروج من
الكنيسه خلال لحظات نرى ان
الملك يتجهز للعربه الذهبيه خلف الملك
سيكون بشكل مباشر الاميره ان وستكون بالذي
العسكري هذا ما نتوقع ستكون خلف عربه
الملك والملكه
اسال اميره ان وهي شقيقه الملك والاكثر
شخص مقرب وتنصح الملك من وقت لاخر
سيكون خلف الاميره ان ولي العهد ايضا
الامير ويليام والاميره كيك زوجته
ولي ولي العهد يعني الثالث في العرش
الامير جورج والاميره شارلر والامير لويس
يعني ولي العهد مع اولاده ثلاثه وزوجته
خلف الاميره
بالعربه الثانيه بعض ولي العهد سيكون زوق
ادم برا وايضا الدجاج وباقي العائله
الملكيه وهناك عربه ثالثه سيكون الدوكلين
وباقي مثلا الفويس
هذه هي التراكبيه وسنرى من الارجح ان يعني
يتم الالتزام بهذا الموضوع لانه جزء من
البروتوكولات وسيكون هناك غياب للامير الي
والامير اندرو
فنذكر لان شعبيه الامير هاري قبل سنوات
كانت الاعلى من ضمن العائله الملكيه ربما
كانت تطابق على الشعبيه فقط الملكه
اليزابيث ولكن
الى ان المستويات من خلال اخر احصاءات
للراي كانت موجوده في بريطانيا ونرى الملك
تشارلز ملكا متزوجا يرتدي التاج
الامبراطوري ويمسك بالكره الذهبيه التي
تشير الى الكره الارضيه والعالم المسيحي
والصولجان الذي يشير الى العرش والرحمه
مسيره داخل كنيسه
والملك يتجهز للخروج من حفله تنصيب وتسويج
وهي مراسم دينيه بحثه لان الملك تشارلز
اصبح فعليا ملكا لحظه وفاه الملكه
اليزابيث وهو يهم الان
بالخروج ربما من
كنيسه ويست مانستر باتجاه العربه الذهبيه
فقط نتابع هذه الصور بصوتها الطبيعي ثم
اعود مره اخرى
[موسيقى]
اذا لا زلنا نتابع واياكم مراسم تتويج
الملك تشارلز الثالث ملكا للمملكه المتحده
هذه التغطيه حيه ومستمره ومباشره على شاشه
العربيه بعد قليل يلتقيكم الزميل ابراهيم
بدر لاستكمال هذه التغطيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات